هل من معلومات عن التحقيق الاولي
للجيش اذا وفق وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
فان التحقيقات الاوليه تشير الى ان
الشاحنه التي كانت تحتوي على مواد متفجره
قد انفجرت بسبب نيران اطلقت من دبابه
اسرائيليه وبالتالي هذا الحدث كان ناجم عن
على ما يبدو خطا عمليات عسكري اسرائيلي
ويضاف الى سلسله ال احداث التي قتل في عد
كبير من الجنود من النيران الصديقه وفق
المعلومات الاوليه فاننا نتحدث عن مقتل
تسعه جنود من بينهم سته جنود قتلوا في هذا
الحادث نتحدث عن شاحنه كانت محمله بمواد
متفجره في طريقها لتدمير انفاق او مصنع
لتصنيع الاسلحه تابع لكتائب عز الدين
القسام بالقرب من مخيم البريج في قطاع غزه
ولكن على ما يبدو انه تم استهداف هذه
الشاحنه عبر نيران اسرائيليه مما ادى الى
فيجار هذا وفق التحقيقات الاوليه
الاسرائيليه يوم امس كان على مستوى
المعارك في قطاع غزه يوم قاسي جدا وفق ما
وصفته وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه لما كبد
الجيش الاسرائيلي من خسائر نتحدث عن اكثر
من 500 جندي وضابط قتل جراء هذه المعارك
التي دائره في قطاع غزه منذ خ 95 يوم نحن
نتحدث على ثلاث وقائع حدثت يوم امس والتي
اودت بحياه عدد كبير من الج نتحدث عن تسعه
جنود من بينهم سته قتلوا في حادث انفجار
الشاحنه من بين هذه الاحداث ايضا كان
تفجير لمنطقه بالالغام مما ادى ايضا الى
مقتل الى مقتل اربعه جنود وايضا كان هنالك
37 ضابط وجندي اصيبوا جراء حادث انفجار
الشاحنه التي كانت تحتوي على مواده متفجره
وبالتالي هذا الامر ايضا يتضاعف وينعكس
على مستوى الشارع الاسرائيلي هنالك ضغط
بوقف اطلاق النار والتوجه الى صفقه والى
حل سياسي للافراج عن صلاح الاسرى الاسرائ